YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLENARCHULETA ATKINS BATES BELL FOR
JUST BRADFORD CABALLERO CHIANG
ALLEY DODD TORONTO GALGIANI
GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG
HELLO WEST SO TADO. JACKSON
JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL
MONNING MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN
PAN PORTANTINO ROUGH RUBIO
SKINNER STERN I'M BURKE LIKE
OWSKI WIENER WILK. LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WE'RE GONNA ASK ALL MEMBERS IN
OUR GAS BE ON THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE RISE
WE'RE GONNA BE LEAD IN PRAYER
THIS AFTERNOON BY OUR GUEST
CHAPLAIN REVEREND CHASING BEEN
SEE UNITED STATES AIRFORCE
CHAPLAIN HE'S A CAPTAIN AT
TRAVIS AIR FORCE BASE AFTER
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ASK ALL OF
YOU PLEASE REMAIN STANDING
WE'RE GONNA BE LED IN THE
NATION'S PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
BY SENATOR MORLOCK. IS RIVER.
ALMIGHTY GOD WE LIVE BEFORE YOU
ALL WHO GOVERN CALIFORNIA. MAKE
US ALWAYS REMEMBER YOUR
GENEROSITY AND GOODNESS. PLUS
OUR STATE WITH HONESTY AND
WORKPLACE. RUTH IN EDUCATION AN
HONOR IN DAILY LIFE. SAVE US
FROM VIOLENCE DISCORD AND
CONFUSION FROM PRIDE AND
ARROGANCE AND CYNICISM AND
DESPAIR. AT THE TIMES WE
PROSPER GIVE US GRATEFUL HEARTS.
IN IN MOMENTS OF TROUBLE TURN
US TO TRUST AND FAITH. WE PRAY
IN THE HOLY AND SACRED NAME OF
ETERNAL GOD. AHMAN. COLLEAGUES
AND GUESTS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I
PLEDGE. THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA HE'S THE REPUBLIC FOR
WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND STUFF. THANK YOU
CAPTAIN. WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR SERVICE AND FOR JOINING US
TODAY. MEMBERS WE HAVE SOME
VERY SPECIAL GAS. HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS TODAY WE WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO WELCOME THREE
FORMER SENATORS AND FORMER
ASSEMBLY WOMAN AND ONE OF THOSE
FORMER SENATORS IS ALSO A
FORMER SECRETARY STATE. WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO WELCOME
SENATOR KEY H
SENATOR KEY Hí TO THE FLOOR
TODAY. WE ARE SO GRATEFUL TO
SEIZE SENATOR OR WALKING HERE
HAPPY NEW YEAR CENTER WILL. IF
WE GET PLEASE GIVE A WELCOME TO
SENATOR FORMER SECRETARY STATE
MISTER MCPHERSON. IN WE ARE
VERY EXCITED THAT RETIRED
ASSEMBLY WOMAN THOMPSON IS HERE
WITH US IF WE CAN GIVE A ROUND
OF APPLAUSE.
THERE. ANYONE WHO
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A
PICTURE WITH THE FOR FORMER
MEMBERS. YOU CAN JOIN THEM
RIGHT THERE IN THE BACK.
A BIG
THANK YOU TO THE FORMER.
SENATORS FOR JOINING US HERE.
ONE MORE PICTURE.
SENATOR
MCGUIRE AT THE PRO TEM'S DESK.
MEMBERS. SENATOR MCGUIRE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. FOR MORE THAN THREE
DECADES SUSAN BRANSON IS
DEDICATED DEDICATED HER LIFE TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
AND WE HAD SOME BITTERSWEET
NEWS SHE'S GOING TO BE
RETIRING. THEY WERE QUITE UPSET
ABOUT IT- TODAY WE WANT TO
RECOGNIZE HER FOR HER TIRELESS
SERVICE. FOR HER OUTSTANDING
WORK IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
LET'S FACE IT CALIFORNIA IS A
HUGE STATE WITH A MASSIVE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM THAT IS
AS DIVERSE AS A POPULATION
ITSELF. THERE ARE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF MILES OF FREEWAYS
AND HIGHWAYS RURAL ROADS AND
BRIDGES BIKE PATHS HIKING
TRAILS A COMMUTER RAILS IN BIG
CITIES AND SMALL IN EVERY
CORNER OF THE GOLDEN STATE. WE
HAVE IT ALL IN ITS NEARLY AN
IMPOSSIBLE JOB TO BE ABLE TO
KEEP TRACK OF ALL THESE
PROJECTS TO FIND THEM IN TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE DONE
PROPERLY. EQUITABLY IN RIGHT.
AND SUSAN BRANSON IS DONE THIS.
AND MORE HER KNOWLEDGE OF THE
STATE IS TRULY IMPRESSIVE
EVERYWHERE THERE ISA NEED WHEN
IT CAME TO TRANSPORTATION SHE
MADE CERTAIN THAT THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION KNEW THE FACTS OF
THE PROJECT RUN THE GROUND AND
BROUGHT SOLUTIONS TO THE TABLE.
HER DEEP AWARENESS OF EACH OF
THE COMMISSION'S PROJECTS NO
MATTER HOW BIG OR SMALL THEY
MIGHT HAVE BEEN HAS BEEN DOWN
RIGHT REMARKABLE. SHE KNOWS THE
HISTORY THE CHALLENGES THE
BENEFITS AND THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN EVERY PROJECT THAT
THE COMMISSION HAS WORKED ON.
NO MATTER WHAT THE LOCATION THE
SIZE OF THE PROJECT TO THE
SCOPE OF THE SOLUTION MISS
FRANCE AND WAS ABLE TO BUILD
THE BRIDGE TO MAKE IT WORK.
HAVING WORKED CLOSELY WITH
MISTRANSLATED YEARS AND I KNOW
MANY IN THIS CHAMBER HAVE AS
WELL I CAN SAY WITHOUT
RESERVATION THAT I AM SO
GRATEFUL. FOR HER ATTENTION TO
THE NEEDS OF OUR RURAL AREAS
AND I KNOW THAT ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO REPRESENT MORE
URBAN AREA FEEL THE SAME. I'LL
BE HAPPY CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE MEMBERS WE WISH SPRINT
THE VERY BEST THE RETURN.
DINNER SO INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL.
RAISING WORK ON BEHALF OF THE
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE MEMBERS
IF YOU COULD PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING THE OUTSTANDING
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR SUSAN. SENATOR NIELSEN.
BETTER PRESENT LAYS DOWN THE
SENATE I'D LIKE TO JOIN INDEED
NOT AGING SUSAN BURKE-
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE JUST LAST WEEK OF
APPEARING BEFORE THAT
COMMISSION. ON AN ISSUE RELATED
TO THE DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT. BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
HER RECORD. IT'S ONE OF THE
EXAMPLE THE ONES IN STATE
GOVERNMENT HOW AN INDIVIDUAL.
COMES INTO A POSITION AND THEN
IT WORKS ARE WAY UP THROUGH AN
ORGANIZATION THE VERY TOP. AND
A SHE'S SERVED IN DIFFERENT
CAPACITIES WITHIN THAT AGENCY
IT'S BETTER ALL THE MORE
CAPABLE OF DOING THE JOB FOR
THE OVERALL AGENCY. AND IT IS A
GOOD AGENCIES SUSAN THANK YOU
FOR THOSE MANY YEARS OF SERVICE
THE LONG AND LABORIOUS DAYS AND
NIGHTS YOU COMMITTED. AND THE
GOOD WORKS THE CALIFORNIANS
ENJOY EACH DAY IS A DRIVE
BECAUSE OF WHAT YOU DID.
MISS
BRANSON THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
YOUR FAMILY HERE TO SHARE IN
THIS RETIREMENT AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE TO CALIFORNIA.
SENATOR SKINNER. SENATOR
SKINNER AT THE PRO TEM'S DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. I HAVE THE GREAT
PRIVILEGE THIS AFTERNOON OF
WELCOMING TO OUR SENATE FLOOR
AND ASKING ALL OF US TO JOIN IN
IN HONORING AMANDA IN NYC
WILCOX WHO ARE. RETIRING FROM
THEIR WORK WE'RE NOT GOING TO
SEE THEM IN THE CAPITAL THE WAY
WE HAVE FOR THE LAST. FIFTEEN
OR SO YEARS. BEFORE I GET INTO
A LITTLE BIT OF- WHAT-
WONDERFUL ACCOMPLISHMENTS. I
WILL SART WITH WHAT BROUGHT
THEM TO THE CAPITOL IN WHY WE
SAW THEM SO MUCH. TRAGICALLY
THEIR DAUGHTER LARA WILCOX WAS
KILLED IN NEVADA COUNTY FROM A
GUNSHOT AT THE AGE OF NINETEEN
FLOORS LAW IS NAMED AFTER HER.
AND IN THE FACE OF SUCH A
TRAGEDY AND I THINK ANY OF US
WHO HAVE LOST A CHILD IS VERY
HARD TO IMAGINE THAT WE WOULD
REALLY BE ABLE TO. JUST POUR
ALL THAT GRIEF INTO SOMETHING
POSITIVE AND YET THEY DID SO
AMANDA FOUNDED THE NEVADA
PLASTER COUNTY CHAPTER OF THE
BRADY. UNITED AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE AND SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND FIVE HAS BEEN IN OUR STATE
CAPITOL REGULARLY. TO BASICALLY
GET US TO ACT WISELY AND TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PREVENT
AND REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE. SO AS
I MENTIONED SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIVE SHE'S BEEN THE LEGISLATION
AND POLICY CHAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE
BREED UNITED AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE BUT IN ADDITION WELL
LET'S STICK TO THAT FOR A
MINUTE. AND IN DOING SO HAS
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN MANY OF
CALIFORNIA'S GOOD GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION LAWS INCLUDING THE
GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER
NOW COMMONLY KNOWN ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS THE RED FOR LAW. AND
WE IN CAL THE WERE THE TO ADMIT
IT SO NOW WE SEE OTHER STATES
FOLLOWING ARE ARE GOOD- ACTION
AND THANK GOODNESS IT WAS
PEOPLE LIKE AMANDA IN NYC. WHO
SHOWED UP HERE WHO BROUGHT US
SUCH IDEAS AND SHOWED UP AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN TO HAVE US
ACT SO SMARTLY. SHE ALSO SERVES
ON THE NEVADA COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH BOARD THE NEVADA COUNTY
SUICIDE PREVENTION BOARD AND
HAS BEEN A FOURTEEN YEAR MEMBER
OF THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARD IN HER AREA TEN
YEARS AS THE PRESIDENT. NOW
NICK WILCOX WHO IS THE CO
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BRADY CHAPTERS UNTIL
TWENTY SIXTEEN WAS ALSO STATED
POINT AND HE'S RETIRED FROM THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD IN TWO THOUSAND AND THREE
HE WAS THE SUPERVISING
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENTISTS IN ALL
THE SCIENTISTS IN THE DIVISION
OF WATER RIGHTS MOST RECENTLY
AS THE CHIEF OF THE BAY DELTA
UNIT. AND BEFORE HE WORKED AN
ENVIRONMENTAL CHEMIST AND HIGH
SCHOOL SCIENCE TEACHER. SO WE
ARE GOING TO MISS BOTH OF THEM.
WORK IN THE HALLS WALKING THE
HALLS TESTIFYING IN COMMITTEE
HI MATCHING WILL SEE THEM A
COUPLE MORE TIMES- BUT I'M JUST
SO GLAD THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
JOIN US ON THE FLOOR TODAY AND
THAT WE ALL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK THEM AND
HONOR THEM. THE. NEWS MEDIA WE
HAVE SOME SENATORS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO- WELCOME OUR
GUESTS IS WELL IF WE CAN HOLD
ON THE PICTURE FOR JUST A
MOMENT WE LIKE TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO SENATOR JACKSON
IN CENTER PORTANTINO. THANK YOU
MISTER A PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
YOU KNOW. WHEN YOU CONSIDER
LIFE AND ALL OF ITS TRIALS AND
TRIBULATIONS SO WE ALL HAVE OUR
SHARE. IT REALLY ISN'T WHAT
HAPPENS TO YOU. THAT MATTERS
IT'S WHAT YOU DO ABOUT IT. AND
IN THE CASE OF THE WILCOX
FAMILY AFTER THE DEATH THE
HORRIBLE DEATH OF THEIR
DAUGHTER AT AGE NINETEEN. THEY
DID SOMETHING ABOUT IT THEY
TOOK THAT EVENT AND THEY TURNED
IT INTO SOMETHING. IN WHICH
THEY COULD HONOR THEIR
DAUGHTER'S MEMORY IN HER LIFE
AND YET DO SOMETHING TO BETTER
LIVES OF ALL OF THE REST OF US.
AND WHETHER YOU BELIEVE IN GUN
CONTROL GUN REGULATION OR WHAT
HAVE YOU. ACTIVE YOUR POLITICAL
VIEWS ON THAT THEY HAVE WORKED
TIRELESSLY WITH MEMBERS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE TO TRY TO REDUCE
GUN VIOLENCE IN OUR STATE
ADDRESSING ISSUES OF MENTAL
HEALTH. WAS MENTIONED LARA'S
LAW I WAS HONORED TO WORK WITH
THEM ON A NUMBER OF BILLS THAT
I BROUGHT- DURING THE COURSE OF
MY CAREER INCLUDING A BILL TO
DO A WELLNESS CHECK WHEN IT
APPEARED THAT SOMEONE WAS HAVE
IT WAS IN CRISIS AND WHETHER OR
NOT THEY HAD FIREARMS SO WE
COULD TRY TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM POTENTIALLY REMOVE
FIREARMS. AND THUS REDUCE THE
INCIDENT OF DAMAGE IN DANGER TO
OTHERS AND SINCE. THEIR
INVOLVEMENT THEY HAVE HELPED TO
ENACT MORE THAN EIGHTY. EIGHTY
GUN SAFETY BILLS IN THE STATE
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY THREE A
RESULT. CALIFORNIA'S FIREARMS
TO HAVE HIM DROP FIFTY SEVEN
PERCENT. IN SIGNIFICANT PART
DUE TO THEIR WORK AND THEIR
INSIGHT INTO TRYING TO ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM SO OTHERS DID NOT
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE PAIN AND
ANGUISH THAT THEY DID. THEY ARE
TRULY HEROES AND I WANT TO
THANK THEM. FOR THEIR GREAT
WORK FOR ALWAYS BEING THERE AND
TWO WE ARE WAS SUCH DIGNITY.
THERE WERE TIMES WHERE I WOULD
GET FRUSTRATED BUT AMANDA WOULD
SIT THERE WITH JUST THE
GREATEST POOR USE AND GRACE AND
MAKE HER CASE. AND THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA ARE SO INDEBTED
TO HER AND TO NEW YORK FOR
THEIR WORK I AM HONORED TO BE
HERE IN YOUR PRESENCE AND TO
THANK YOU FOR THE EXTRAORDINARY
WORK YOU'VE DONE ON BEHALF OF
THE PEOPLE OF OUR STATE. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS OF THE SENATE WE
LIKE TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR PORTANTINO. I JUST WANT
TO ADD MY VOICE TO WHAT'S BEEN
SAID TODAY- THE WILCOX'S ARE AN
AMAZING COUPLE. TO COME OUT OF
A TRAGEDY LIKE THAT- IT'S EASY
TO BE BETTER TO BE ANGRY. BUT
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN THAT IN THEIR
FACE AND THEIR DEPARTMENT IN
THEIR MANNER IN A WORM I MEAN
HOW I'M THE FATHER OF TWO
DAUGHTERS IN YOU KNOW I DON'T
KNOW IF I COULD OF HANDLED
THINGS THE WAY YOU TO HAVE THIS
BROUGHT PRIDE TO YOUR FAMILY
AND SAFETY THE CALIFORNIA- WE
ARE JUST AMAZING NICE WONDERFUL
PEOPLE WITH A PASSION TO SHARE
THAT WITH THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE SAFER
TODAY. BECAUSE OF THE TWO OF
YOU AND SO I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTERS WE
NOW WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
SENATOR MARLA. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. IN JULY OF TWENTY
ELEVEN A YOUNG MAN WITH
SCHIZOPHRENIA HOMELESS WAS.
KILLED IN FULLER TEN. AND EARLY
THE NEXT TUESDAY AT THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS MEETING WE HAD
THE PUBLIC COM. AND THEY SAID
YOU KNOW IF ORANGE COUNTY WOULD
HAVE ADOPTED LAURA'S LAW. MAYBE
KELLY THOMAS WOULD BE ALIVE
TODAY. AND AS A SUPERVISOR I
ASKED AT THE DíAS WHAT IS THE
FLOOR IS LAW. I DIDN'T KNOW.
ELEVEN PASSED I BELIEVE. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO. BY THE HARD WORK
OF ASSEMBLYWOMAN HELEN THOMSON
WHO'S HERE TODAY. AND ONLY
NEVADA COUNTY WERE LARA WILCOX
WAS MURDERED WAS- WAS THE ONLY
COUNTY THAT ADOPTED LORDS LAW
IN SO I TURNED TO MY SHERIFF
INTO MY- PRESIDING JUDGE INTO
MY PUBLIC DEFENDER AND TO. WE
ALL LOOKED AT EACH OTHER SAID
HOW DO WE HOW DO WE BUDGET FOR
IMPLEMENTING LAURA'S LAW. AND
WE WORKED FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND
THEN I WORK WITH SENATOR GERALD
STEINBERG AND- HE GAVE US SB
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE WHICH ALLOWED
A LITTLE BIT OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACTIVE FUND FOR
LORDS LAW. THAT WAS SIGNED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN. AND ORANGE
COUNTY BECAME THE SECOND COUNTY
TO ADOPT LORD IS LAW WE'VE HAD
SEVENTEEN COUNTIES. ADOPT
FLOORS LOS SENSE A STUDY CAME
OUT LAST YEAR. AND ASKED WHY
DON'T THE OTHER THIRTY EIGHT
SOME ODD COUNTIES ADOPT LORDS
LAW. SO IT IS AN HONOR. TO
RECOGNIZE YOU TO. HI WE'VE SORT
OF BEEN. CONNECTED SOMEHOW OVER
THE YEARS AND- JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR SERVICE.
THANK YOU SIR. SEEN IT ALL
DISCUSSION HAS SEIZE WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO OPEN
UP. A PHOTO. ON BEHALF OF THE
SENATE. COX'S WE ALSO WELCOME.
SENATOR WOKEN CINNAMON THOMPSON
TO BE A TO JOIN THE PHOTO AS
WELL.
THANK YOU TO THE WILCOX'S
FOR BEING HERE TODAY AND-
TENACIOUS FIGHT. GOING TO GIVE
IT A- THIRTY SECONDS TO A
MINUTE WHAT FOLKS. HAVE SOME
TIME WITH THE WILCOX'S IN MORE.
GET STARTED HERE IN JUST A
MOMENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
THE SENATE WE'D LIKE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH. OUR BUSINESS HERE
TODAY. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THIS IS SIMPLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES YOU GOT IT THEY'RE
GONNA BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN ADOPTED.
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES ANY MEMBERS WOULD
LIKE THERE TO MAKE. ANY ACTION
UNDER THIS ITEM HEARING SEEN
NINE WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS MISTER SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL.
904-905-9069 OH SEVEN. NINE OH
EIGHT NINE OH NINE. NINE TEN.
NINE ELEVEN. NINE TWELVE NINE
THIRTEEN AND SENATE BILL NINE
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO OUR- BUSINESS OF
THE DAY UNDER CONSIDERATION THE
DAILY FILE EARNERS SENATE THIRD
READING. SENATE GALGIANI
PREPARED TO PRESENT SHE IS MR
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY NINE BY SENATOR
GALGIANI RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
GIRLS AND WOMEN IN SPORTS DAY
GOOD AFTERNOON CENTER GALGIANI
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT S. C. R. SEVENTY
NINE. TO MARK THE FIRST
WEDNESDAY IN FEBRUARY AS
CALIFORNIA GIRLS AND WOMEN IN
SPORTS DAY. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO THE YEAR THAT TITLE NINE
WAS INTRODUCED JUST ONE IN
TWENTY SEVEN GIRLS PARTICIPATED
IN HIGH SCHOOL VARSITY SPORTS
OR ABOUT THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
GIRLS. FORTY EIGHT YEARS LATER
S. C. AREN'T MANY NINE
CELEBRATES THE TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS MADE AS ABOUT THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION GIRLS
PARTICIPATED IN HIGH SCHOOL
SPORTS IN THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SCHOOL.
PARTICIPATION IS PROVEN TO HAVE
A POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE MEND
AND SOCIAL WELL BEING HEALTHY
HABITS AND THE PROMOTION OF
CONFIDENCE AND LEADERSHIP
SKILLS FOR YOUNG GIRLS.
ADDITIONALLY EVIDENCE SHOWS
THAT ATHLETIC HAVE ACTIVITY
HELPS WOMEN OVERCOME CULTURAL
AND ECONOMIC BARRIERS TO THEIR
ADVANCEMENT. THIS INCLUDES
HIGHER ACHIEVEMENT IN SCHOOL
AND IN FIELDS GENERALLY
DOMINATED BY MEN SUCH AS
SCIENCE AND MATH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME IN VOTING
EYED TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SENATOR MEMBERS WE
HAVE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR. BLACKS CALLED
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. HEARING SEEN NINE. THREE
GALGIANI WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. I CAN BY BATES HI
BEL HI PORCHES HI BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO HI CHIANG HI SALLY HI
DON I THRUST SO HI GALGIANI.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI GROVE HI
HERTZBERG HI HILL. I WAS SO HI
DONNA HI JACKSON HI JONES BY
LEYVA HI MCGUIRE. MITCHELL
MONNING HI MORE LOOK HIGH
MORALE. HI NIELSEN. TEN HI
PORTANTINO I BY ROTH HI RUBIO.
HI SKINNER HI STERN HI NUMBER.
WHY CASKEY. HI WIENER. HI WILK
HI. MISTER SECRETARY IF YOU
COULD PLEASE CALL. THE ABSENT
MEMBERS GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. HI
NIELSEN. HUMBERT NIELSEN AYE
I'M BURKE. TIES THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
THANK YOU MEMBERS. SENATORS ARE
NOW MOVING TO BACK TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS THIS IS A TIME
TO ADDRESS THE SENATE WITH A
JOURNEY MEMORIES. WE'RE GONNA
GO DOWN THE LINE STARTING WITH
CENTER PRO TEM SENATOR ATKINS.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY TO A JUROR IN MEMORY
OF PAMELA LYNN SCANLON'S WHO
PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY NINTH
AFTER AN INCREDIBLE TEN YEAR
BATTLE WITH CANCER. PAM MADE
HER HOME IN SAN DIEGO SHE
ATTENDED AND GRADUATED FROM SAN
DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY. SHE
BEGAN HER CAREER ASSISTING LAW
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS TO SOLVE
CRIMES THROUGH TECHNOLOGY.
SHE'S CONSIDERED A PIONEER IN
THE FIELD OF USING COMPUTERS
AND DATA ANALYSIS TO PREVENT
AND SOLVE CRIME. IN NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN SHE BECAME THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
AUTOMATED REGIONAL INFORMATION
SYSTEM IN SAN DIEGO WE CALL
THAT ARE JUST. AN INTEGRATED
JUSTICE ENTERPRISE NETWORK IN
SYSTEM USED BY OVER EIGHTY TWO
LOCAL STATE AND FEERAL
AGENCIES. SHE RECEIVED NUMEROUS
AWARDS FOR HER WORK AND WAS A
NATIONALLY AND INTERNATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED EXPERT FIELD. I'LL
MENTION JUST A FEW OF THE
AWARDS THAT SHE RECEIVED HERO
OF THE NEW INTERNET BY BUSINESS
WEEK FBI DIRECTOR'S AWARD
AWARDS FROM EVERY FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY THE NATIONAL
INTEGRATED JUSTICE SYSTEMS
SHUMATE AWARD. THE NATIONAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT INFORMATION AND
TECHNOLOGY AWARD WE MANY OF US
I THINK WHEN WE FIRST STARTED
OUT IN SAN DIEGO AND SERVED ON
SAND DAG ARE-PLANNING
ORGANIZATION- AND NTS ARE
REGIONAL TRANSIT BOARD I DON'T
THINK WE KNEW THAT WE HAD THE
EXPERT. IN THE COUNTRY RIGHT IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND THERE'S SO
OFTEN YOU SORT OF TAKE IT FOR
GRANTED AND YOU COULD WITH PAM.
BECAUSE SHE WAS JUST A REGULAR
PERSON AT DO AN INCREDIBLE JOB
TO TELL STORIES ABOUT SOMETHING
GOING AWRY. THIS CONNECTIONS
LOS BAG ODDS POSITIONS ON
PLANES ARE SLUMPED OVER LUGGAGE
IN AIRPORTS THE LIST WAS ALWAYS
IN LISTS AND ABSOLUTELY
HYSTERICAL. I WAS IN HER
SERVICE ARE ON SATURDAY AND IT
WAS JUST INCREDIBLE TO SEE- THE
CHURCH FILLED TO CAPACITY-
BECAUSE OF THE WORK THAT SHE
HAD DONE- ALL THESE DECADES.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND
AT LIEU SCANLON WHO IS THE
FORMER ASSISTANT POLICE CHIEF
IN SAN DIEGO- AND LATER BECAME
THE POLICE CHIEF IN THE CITY OF
CORONADO BOTH COMMUNITIES THAT
I REPRESENT. ANDCERTAINLY- LOU
WAS WELL KNOWN BECAUSE OF HIS
LAW ENFORCEMENT BACKGROUND BUT
IT REALLY WAS PAM- THAT PEOPLE
TURN TO- FOR LOTS OF
INFORMATION AND OFTEN HE HAD TO
ATTEND EVENTS WITH HER. BECAUSE
SHE WAS THE ONE BEING
RECOGNIZED FOR THE WORK THAT
SHE DID. HER DAUGHTER MEGAN APT
HER BROTHER MARK BEARDSLEY AND
HER SISTER AMY WARNS WERE THERE
AS WERE NUMEROUS NIECES GRAND
NIECES. GRAND NEPHEWS- IT WAS A
REALLY WONDERFUL SERVICE AND I
KNOW MOST OF YOU ATTEND
SERVICES OP CELEBRATIONS OF
LIFE FOR PEOPLE IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES. AND IT GIVES YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEE PEOPLE
IN A WAY- THAT YOU MIGHT NOT
HAVE OTHERWISE SEEN AND JUST TO
SEE HER FAMILY AND THE LARGER
COMMUNITY COMING TOGETHER TO
CELEBRATE HER LIFE WAS REALLY
WONDERFUL. SO PLEASE- JOIN ME
IN HONORING THE MEMORY OF PAM
SCANLON. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT PRO TEM AND PLEASE
PASS ALONG OUR DEEPEST
SYMPATHIES OF THE FAMILY.
MEMBERS WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR JONES. THIS IS CENTER.
THANK YOU SENATORS. IT IS- AN
HONOR TODAY- BUT ALSO REGRETFUL
THAT- WE WILL BE ADJOURNING IN
MEMORY OF THE TENET FIRST
LIEUTENANT RYAN MICHAEL O'BRIEN.
AND YOU MAY- REMEMBER HIM ON
THE FLOOR LAST YEAR HERE YEAH
WE ALL DID A RESOLUTION
RECOGNIZING. HIS SERVICE TO OUR
COUNTRY HE PASSED AWAY ON
NOVEMBER TWENTY FOURTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN- SOME OF US
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY OUR PICTURE
TAKEN WITH THE TENANT RYAN WHEN
HE WAS ON THE FLOOR. AND I
WOULD I INVITE YOU ALL TO. AND
IT WILL WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE
PASS IT ON. AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE LIEUTENANT O'BRIEN
ENTERED THE U. S. AIR FORCE AND
EVENTUALLY JOINED A TEN MAN
BOMBING CREW STATIONED OUT OF
MARCH AIRFORCE BASE IN
RIVERSIDE. THE GENERAL BRIAN
AND HIS CREW WERE DISPATCHED TO
THE EUROPEAN THEATER
SPECIFICALLY THE BATTLE TO TAKE
BACK SOUTHERN FRANCE. O'BRIEN
IS CREW FLEW THIRTY FIVE
MISSIONS TOGETHER. AN
UNBELIEVABLE NUMBER OF FLIGHTS
AND BE TWENTY FOUR HOURS IN
WORLD WAR TWO. ON THAT LAST
MISSION ON THEIR BE TWENTY FOUR
IT THERE THE PLANE WAS RIDDLED
WITH SHOTS. BUT THE SHELLS DID
NOT EXPLODE. YOU MAY REMEMBER
THAT HE SHARED A LITTLE BIT OF
THAT STORY. THEY WERE ONE OF
THE MANY OF THE ALLIED FORCES
THAT WERE SAVED BY OSCAR
SCHINDLER'S LIST OF TWELVE
HUNDRED JEWS. THAT SECRETLY
SABOTAGED AND SLOWED THE
PRODUCTION OF GERMAN AMMUNITION.
WHAT THEY DID IS IN THE YOU
KNOW THEY WERE THEY WERE FORCED
TO WORK IN THE FACTORIES MAKING
THE AMMUNITION. BUT THEY WERE
SO CREATIVE AND- FOR THINKING
THAT THEY PULLED THE EXPLOSIVE
PANS OUT OF THE SHELLS SO WHEN
THEY HIT THE PLANES RATHER THAN
THE SHELL EXPLODING AND JUST
KEPT ON TRAVELING THROUGH THE
AIRPLANE. AND THE AIRPLANE WAS
SAVED IN THAT HAPPENED TO
SEVERAL CREWS. IN WORLD WAR TWO.
FIRST A TENER RYAN- BRIAN WAS
AWARDED THE DISTINGUISHED
FLYING CROSS. FOR AIR MEDALS
THE PURPLE HEART. AND THE
EUROPEAN AFRICAN MIDDLE EASTERN
METAL WITH THREE BATTLE STARS.
THEY ALSO RECEIVE FRANCE'S
HIGHEST CIVILIAN HONOR THE
LEGION OF HONOR METAL. AFTER
WORLD WAR TWO RYAN O'BRIEN
RETURN TO CIVILIAN LIFE THEY
KEPT ACTIVE WITH NUMEROUS
VETERANS GROUPS AND ALSO WAS
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE
MASONS ASSOCIATION. FIRST
LIEUTENANT REID O'BRIEN WAS
TRULY ONE OF THE GREATEST
GENERATION. AND WILL BE MISSED
BY HIS MANY FRIENDS NEIGHBORS
AND FAMILY MEMBERS AND THE
REASON I'M UP HERE IN FRONT AS
I WANTED TO RECOGNIZE THE MANY
VETERANS GROUPS THAT ARE IN THE
GALLERY. INCLUDING A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE FRENCH
GOVERNMENT IT IS YOUR HONOR
LIEUTENANT RYAN O'BRIEN TODAY
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR SERVICE.
I THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
TODAY. WE WELCOME YOU TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. AND
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR SACRIFICE
AND SERVICE. MEMBERS ON THIS
ITEM WE LIKE TO TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO SENATOR ROBB. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT THANKS TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTEE FOR
ALLOWING. ME TO JOIN HIM IN
THIS ADJOURNED IN MEMORY. YOU
KNOW SIXTEEN MILLION AMERICANS
SERVED IN WORLD WAR TWO. BUT
LESS THAN SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
THAN FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND.
MAIN ALIVE TODAY. AND THEY TELL
ME WE'RE LOSING. THESE WERE
WERE TO VETERANS AT A RATE OF
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
TWO. PER DAY. FRANKLY TIME IS
RUNNING OUT. HEAR THEIR STORIES
AND HONOR THEIR SACRIFICE. I
WAS PRIVILEGED TO FIRST MEET
LIEUTENANT BRIAN IN MARCH OF
LAST YEAR THANKS AGAIN TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTEE WHO
INTRODUCED ME. WAS WHEN. THE
SENATOR INTRODUCED HIM ON OUR
SENATE FLOOR. I ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY- THE NEXT MONTH IN
APRIL OF TWO AGAIN. MEETS THE
TENER BRIAN AND HAVE A MORE
DETAILED CONVERSATION WITH THEM
DOWNSTAIRS IN THIS VERY
BUILDING WHEN HE WAS ATTENDING.
VETERANS EVENT. I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO HIM I
HAD A NEW OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
HIM QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS WARTIME
SERVICE. FRANKLY QUESTIONS THAT
I WAS NEVER ABLE TO ASK MY OWN
FATHER. AT THE TIME I LEARNED
THAT HE IN FACT. HAD TRAINED
WITH THIS CREW OF TEN. AT MARCH
FIELD JUST OUTSIDE RIVERSIDE IN
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR. A DURING
THE WAR AND FREQUENTED OUR OWN
HISTORIC MISSION IN IN THOSE
DAYS AS MANY. SERVICE MEN AND
WOMEN. HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
IT WAS QUITE A CONVERSATION AT
LEAST FOR ME. AT THE TIME I
INVITED HIM TO JOIN ME IN
RIVERSIDE AND OFFERED TO HOST.
A REUNION FOR THE LIEUTENANT
AND HIS COMRADES IN THE FORTY
FOURTH BOMB GROUP. AT THE
HISTORIC MISSION AND IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN THIS YEAR HIS SEVENTY
SIX IF MY MATH IS CORRECT I'M
SURE I'LL BE CORRECTED SEVENTY
SIX THREE UNION. UNFORTUNATELY
HE DID NOT MAKE. OUR MAKER
OBVIOUSLY HAD OTHER PLANS FOR
HIM. BUT AS WE REMEMBER HIS
SERVICE AND HIS SACRIFICE TODAY
WE DO SO KNOWING. HE CONTINUES
TO SERVE JUST A HIGHER BECAUSE
THANK YOU SIR. TO BOTH SENATORS
THANK YOU FOR THAT TOUCHING
TRIBUTE. AND PLEASE SEND OUR
SYMPATHIES ON BEHALF OF THE
SENATE TO THE FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. SENATORS WE'D LIKE TO
TURN OUR ATTENTION TO SENATOR
JACKSON YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES IT'S WITH A HEAVY
HEART THAT I STAND TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY. OF A FAVORITE
SON OF THE GREAT CITY OF OXNARD
DOCTOR MANY LOPEZ WHO DIED LAST
WEEK AT THE RIPE YOUNG AGE OF
NINETY TWO. HE WAS A NATIVE SON
OF OXNARD HIS PARENTS SHOULD
COME HERE THE FLEA THE MEXICAN
REVOLUTION AND IT'S CONTINUING
CONFLICTS. HE GREW UP IN
IMPOVERISHED CIRCUMSTANCES BUT
HE WAS DETERMINED TO MAKE
SOMETHING OF HIS LIFE IN SPITE
OF THE FACT THAT HE SUFFERED
FROM TUBERCULOSIS. AS A CHILD
AND ULTIMATELY LOST ONE LONG.
HE WENT TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND THEN HE TRANSFERRED TO
BERKELEY UC BERKELEY WHERE HE
GOT HIS UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE
AND HIS DEGREE IN OPTOMETRY. HE
OPENED A PRACTICE IN OXNARD AT
A TIME WHERE THERE WERE NOT TOO
MANY PEOPLE OF MEXICAN DESCENT
WHO WERE. NEEDED TO PRACTICE A
PROFESSION EVEN THOUGH OXNARD
IS A COMMUNITY THAT HAS A VERY
HAS HAD A VERY RICH- MEXICAN
TRADITION FOR DECADES. HE WAS A
MAN A GENTLE MAN AND YET A MAN
OF FIRM CONVICTION HE WOULD
FREQUENTLY GIVE HIS SERVICES TO
THOSE WHO COULD NOT AFFORD TO
PAY HIM. HE WAS COMMITTED TO
ITS COMMUNITY AND AS A RESULT
AS FAR BACK AS NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT HE WAS FIRST ELECTED TO
THE OXNARD CITY COUNCIL HE
SERVED UNTIL TWO THOUSAND AND
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EXCUSE ME
IN NINETEEN NINETY. IN NINETEEN
TWO HE BECAME IT'S FORTINO
MAYOR. THIS IS A COMMUNITY THAT
SAYS OUR CHAVEZ SPENT TIME AT
UNDERSTANDING IT WAS IMPORTANT
TO START BROWSING THE COMMUNITY
WHO ARE ALL FARMWORKERS FOR
MANY OF WHOM WERE FARMWORKERS
AND WE'RE NOT BEING TREATED
WITH THAT LEVEL OF DIGNITY AND
RESPECT THAT THEY WERE.
ENTITLED TO RECEIVE AND DOCTOR
LOPEZ WAS THERE. AS A
LEGISLATOR I SHOULD SAY IS A
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER AND AS THE
MAYOR- WITH THE SUPPORT OF SAYS
OUR JOB IS TO GIVE THE PEOPLE
OF THAT COMMUNITY A VOICE. IN
THE MATTERS THAT WERE REALLY
AFFECTING THEIR DAILY LIVES HE
WAS ABLE TO WARD OFF A EFFORTS
TO BUILD A CASINO IN A
LIQUEFIED NATURAL GAS PROJECT
AGAIN. IN AN ENVIRONMENTALLY
SENSITIVE AREA BUT BY
ENVIRONMENTALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY BUT WHAT HE DID DO AS
WELL WHICH HE HELPED TO BUILD A
LIBRARY. AN OF VETERANS REMOTE
MEMORIAL IN THE DOWNTOWN OXNARD
AREA SO THAT THE COMMUNITY
CONNECT AND BE PART OF A
CELEBRATION. OF LEARNING AND
SERVICE. MANNY YEAH WAS A GOOD
FRIEND- BIG SUPPORTER DIDN'T
HAVE A LOT TO SAY. IS WHAT PER
MONTH INFORMATION. IN SYMPATHY
AND CONDOLENCES- REAL SPOKE. OF
VERY STRONG. AND MANY THERE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHAT BERMAN
WANTED HAPPENED. THEY WERE
QUITE A TEAM THEY ARE QUITE A
TEAM I KNOW IN HER SADNESS IN
THE SADNESS OF THE FAMILY THEY
ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
FACT THAT MANY DID HELP TO MOVE
THIS COMMUNITY FORWARD WE WILL
MISS HIM I WILL MISS HIM
PERSONALLY HE WAS A REAL
PRESENCE IN THE UC TO THE
COMMUNITY. AND WITH THAT MISTER
PRESIDENT I WOULD ASK THAT WE
ENSURING IN THE MEMORY OF
DOCTOR MEN WILL LOTUS THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THAT
PLEASE PASS SENATE SYMPATHIES.
SENATE HUESO THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS UP PLEASE. JOIN ME IN
A JOURNEY IN TODAY'S MEETING IN
THE MEMORY OF GENE AND DRUG
METAL A CHERISHED MEMBER OF THE
SAN DIEGO AND SANTEE SEE THE
ROLE COMMUNITIES SHE WAS BORN
IN NINETEEN FORTY THREE AND
MADE THE COMMUNITY OF SUNNY SEE
THEIR- HER HOME FOR THE PAST
FORTY ONE YEARS IN HER TIME IN
OUR COMMUNITY SHE WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO IMPROVE THE LIVES
OF CHILDREN AND RESIDENTS
THROUGHOUT. WITH HER
INVOLVEMENT IN THE SUNNY
SEETHER WOMEN'S CLUB AS AN
ELECTED TRUSTEE OF THE SENATE
ZERO SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR ELEVEN
YEARS. SHE WAS OF. A FIGHTING
FORCE THAT- LED TO THE
REBUILDING OF. OF A YOU KNOW
IT'S A SMALL DISTRICT AND SHE-
WAS ABLE TO MASTER MIND THE
REBUILDING OF. TEN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL DISTRICT CAMPUS ALL IN
ONE OF. MY EFFORT THIS IS A
DISTRICT THAT IS HAS A- VERY
LOW REVENUES AND IT'S A VERY
UNDER SERVICE DISTRICTS OVER
ACCOMPLISHMENT. WAS ENORMOUS
AND IT MADE A DEEP IMPACT IN
THE LIVES OF THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COMMUNITY. HER LOVE FOR HER
COMMUNITY INSPIRED HER TO TAKE
ON LEADER A LEADERSHIP ROLE AND
SERVE- IN MULTIPLE TERMS AS THE
PRESIDENT. FOR THE SENATE SEAT
A WOMEN'S CLUB. INSTITUTING A
SCHOLARSHIP FUND FOR THE
STUDENTS OF SUNNY TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT. A TWO ALL THOSE
AROUND HER SHE SKIMMED. OF
DETERMINATION AND PERSEVERANCE.
SHE INSPIRED HER LOVE ONES AND
THOSE WHO KNEW OR TO PURSUE
THEIR PASSIONS. AND FOR HER FOR
HER THOUGH IF YOU KNEW HER YOU
KNOW THERE TO HER PASSION WAS
HER FAMILY SHE IS SURVIVED BY
HER HUSBAND OF SIXTY YEARS
ANTHONY HER TWO DAUGHTERS TONI
ROYAL BERRY VALERIE FOR METAL
PART PATRON AND HER SON JASON
DRUM METAL SHE ALSO LEAVES FOUR
GRANDSONS THREE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND SEVERAL
EXTENDED FAMILY AND FRIENDS AT
ALL MISTER DEALER DEARLY JEANS
PASSING IS A TREMENDOUS LOSS.
TO THE COMMUNITY SAID YOU SEE
THERE ON ASH RESPECTFULLY THAT
WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER SENATOR. MEMBERS IT'S
GOING TO CONCLUDE OUR JOURNEY
MEMORIES IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS BETTER PRO TEM THE
DESK IS QUICK THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I WILL SEE YOU AFTER
A BUSY WEEK I'M SURE ON
THURSDAY FEBRUARY SIXTH AT NINE
AM THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER I
CAN SENATORS THIS AND IT'S
GOING TO BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH THE
GERMAN MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE'RE GONNA RECONVENE THURSDAY
AT NINE AM HAVE A GREAT WEEK.
WE'LL TALK JOHN THURSDAY.